-We're back with my family,
everyone,
and like I said, it's so nice
to be together again
and continue this tradition.
Another tradition
is that every year
we have dressed up
first my son Ashe,
and then when he was born,
my son Ashe and Axel
and our dog, Frisbee,
as turkeys.
This is something
we're going to continue to do
until they get too old
where they don't want
to do it anymore.
-Yeah, about 20, 22.
-Yeah.
-The dog has never
really been into it.
-No, and, in fact, keep an eye
out for a couple things.
One, do you think the dog
likes being in this video?
And, two, keep your eye out.
If you peel your eyes
very closely,
there's sort of an Easter egg
that maybe you will find.
But, again, watch very closely.
Here are the boys and Frisbee
as turkeys.
-Boggle, boggle, boggle!
Thanksgiving!
[ Giggling ]
-Boggle, boggle, boggle!
Happy Thanksgiving!
One, two, three. Surprise!
[ Audience awws ]
[ Applause ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We had another one, you guys!
We had another one!
[ Applause ]
This is --
10 weeks ago, my wife gave birth
to a baby girl, and...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I feel like
it's only fitting for you
to tell everybody
what her name is.
-Oh, my gosh.
Her name is Adelaide.
Addie, after my mother.
-Yes.
-Which --
So, I knew,
knowing Seth and Alexi,
it had to start with an "A,"
it had to be a cool name.
And I know what family
means to all of them.
So I thought I pretty much
had it, but I didn't know.
And I didn't want to ask.
-Yep.
-And so it waited.
You waited until we were
on the vineyard. Something.
It was a rainy day.
And then you said,
"Do you want to know the name?"
And I said,
"I guess so. Yes."
And then, of course,
I burst into tears.
-You burst into tears. And, now,
Dad, had it been a boy,
what was the name
that you were arguing for?
-Albert.
-And do you want to explain
what our hesitation
would have been
to naming a child Albert?
-I've had six dogs named Albert.
-Yeah.
-Um, I currently have
Albert VI...
but I thought it would
have been a good name
because it would have been like,
you know --
I've had -- Five of my Alberts
have died.
They had good lives.
Don't worry.
But I thought it would be
like Pinocchio, you know?
And all of a sudden,
the dog turns into a kid.
They went and screwed it up
having a girl.
-Yeah. I, um -- I do --
I only -- You know,
I'm so happy to have a girl.
It was a dream come true
to have a girl,
but I only wish
it had been a boy
just for you to explain
to my wife,
"It's like the dog
came back as a kid."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
It could have gone better
than we all think.
-Now, Addie had
a drink of choice.
Posh, do you remember
what Addie drank?
-Kir Royale.
-Yes, this is --
Not the baby Addie,
but the dear departed Addie.
And so I would like
to take a toast
in memory of
our grandmother and --
-My mother.
-Your mother.
And, Dad, your arch nemesis.
[ Laughter ]
-Cheers.
-To Addie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And if I could just interject
something about Kirs.
Now, it's white wine
with crème de cassis.
The Royale is with champagne,
as well.
But my mother had a flask
that she carried with her
at all times
that had the crème de cassis
because she says
it's such a rip-off
when you go to restaurants,
so a regular glass of white wine
is maybe $6,
then they jack it up to 10
just by putting in
the crème de cassis.
And she says half the time, it's
too red, it's not red enough.
She said,
"I'm just gonna do my own."
So she always took along
this flask and would pour it.
Now, the thing is, with crème
de cassis, it's, like, a real
gooey, red...
-Yeah, very thick.
-Very thick.
-So, one time, the thing broke.
The lid came off.
We were in a store shopping.
And I looked down,
and it was, like,
one of those straw rugs,
and there was crème de --
It looked like somebody
had been murdered.
-Yeah.
-And there was --
There was just red all the way,
and I looked at Mother,
and she said,
"We need to leave right now."
-Yeah.
-So we got out. We got out.
-The point of that story is she
didn't only carry that flask
when she went shopping.
-Yeah.
-Or to the restaurant.
Always had it.
-It's very funny to think of...
carrying a flask full
of crème de cassis.
She was a very refined dirt bag.
-Oh, yes.
-Yeah.
-Wait a minute!
-[ Laughter ]
-But it's very funny about --
Addie --
First of all, here --
I do want to show how beautiful
my grandmother was.
There she is on her wedding day
in the middle.
Here she is right there.
And that's you right there, Mom.
-Yeah. That's with five
of her six children.
-Yep. You had one more baby
after you.
-One more baby.
-And Addie was so refined
and so classy,
and her home was filled
with beautiful antiques.
I assumed until
I was about 15 years old that --
I just assumed she was born
in England.
-Right.
-Do you want to tell everybody
where she was born?
-Kansas City, Missouri.
-Yeah.
-But she was sent
to an English boarding school.
She went to Malvern
Girls College in England.
And she did -- She would
pronounce "luh-bore-atory"
and things like --
She had airs.
-Yeah, she put on airs.
Now, you -- Late in life --
Because she spent her
later years in San Diego.
You were in L.A -- You saw her
a great deal more than I did.
You were very close with her,
but do you have a memory of --
Because she wasn't the warmest
grandmother when we were young.
-No, she didn't like kids
that weren't her kids.
And I was her grandchild.
-Right, which you feel like
is close enough.
-Not for Addie.
-No. No.
-And, yeah, but she was --
Like, you know, she would never
say "paper muh-shay."
She would say papier maché.
-Right.
And then she'd like...
[ Laughter ]
-And then have a nice,
thick drink of cassis.
But she -- I mean,
my favorite story --
She was, you know,
our grandmother.
She was like 83,
had gone through
a couple husbands,
and had gone out
on a date with this guy,
and he was also
getting on in years,
and he was dropping her off,
and he asked her something.
I forget how he phrased it.
What did he ask her?
-"Would you touch it?"
[ Laughter ]
-She did not.
-But that gentleman
would die three months later
and leave his house
to his housekeeper.
And everyone was like,
"Well, if you would've
touched it...
maybe free house."
-It was a very loving
group of people.
How is -- How did your, uh --
What is your memory of Addie?
-It was different for me.
[ Laughter ]
I'm gonna tell you
the first time I met Addie.
Hillary and I met in college,
and I must have been about 20,
and my friend Denny Miller
and I went up --
We lived in Pittsburgh.
We went up to
Marblehead, Massachusetts,
this beautiful New England town
with a big harbor
full of sailboats.
And they lived in a house
that was built in the 1600s.
And we come up there,
and, you know, to have a thing
at the end of the summer,
a little vacation.
And so I think we got off
to a bad start.
You know, first of all,
we mentioned --
She said,
"How do you like Marblehead?"
We said, "Eh.
No rivers, no bridges.
It's not Pittsburgh.
Eh, it's all right."
So, then we were sitting
in the yard and --
-The garden.
-It was the garden. Pardon me.
-If you say "papier maché"...
-You say "garden."
-...you say "garden."
-And I'll admit.
We were 20 years old.
I mean, I don't know
what she was expecting.
She wasn't expecting me.
And, um...
You know, as far as
savoir faire went,
to stay with the French,
ours was only faire.
And so we're sitting
in the garden,
and Hillary's grandfather
came in, Addie's father.
He was quite old at the time
and with a beret
and some medals
from World War I.
And he sat down.
We shook his hand,
but we didn't get up.
We should have got up.
We were, you know --
Again, faire
on the savoir faire.
And so after we had
that little exchange,
we went in to change for dinner,
and Hillary came up and said,
"You have to get out."
Addie threw me out
the first day.
I didn't make it one day.
She threw us out.
And you saw the picture of her
with five of her six children.
And she was the matriarch.
She was --
She was -- I would say she was
like Catherine the Great.
Except Catherine the Great
didn't have six kids.
She was more like that guy...
What's his name on "Succession"?
Roy?
-Logan Roy.
-She was more like him.
-Oh, that's lovely.
-Yeah, with a lot of kids.
-He's very --
He's loving, yeah.
-Yeah.
So she was -- she was the boss.
But we -- you know, we --
That was a rough start.
But, you know, Hillary and I've
been married over 50 years,
and so, over time,
you know, maybe 10,
12 years, things got better.
[ Laughter ]
You know, the last 30 years
were pretty good.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I should note the story
about Addie's birth
was a lot less dramatic
than Axel,
who was my middle son who was
famously born in a lobby.
And our first son
was almost born in an Uber.
So Alexi was very aware
that she has pretty fast labors,
and so she decided to have it
at home with a midwife.
And my wife is very --
She is an alpha.
She likes to plan things.
She put our two boys to bed.
She looked at me, she said,
"My water broke."
We had a midwife
come to our home,
and she gave birth in our
bathtub at 10:30 at night,
which was incredible.
Like three pushes,
and baby Addie was there.
And it was amazing because,
you know, you go to a hospital,
which we did for the first two,
and, you know,
it feels very medical,
and this birth was very much
just felt like a miracle.
And we had -- Addie slept
between us at night in bed.
And then, when the boys
woke up in the morning,
I got to go into
their room and say,
"There's a surprise
for you in Mom's bed."
And here is the video
of the first time
they got to hold their sister.
[ Both laugh ]
Mommy, get her off, get her off.
-Take her off?
[ Laughter ]
-Mommy.
-What?
-What is that?
-That's her belly button.
[ Laughter ]
-We took advantage
of the pandemic
and the fact that you weren't --
you know,
people weren't seeing you out
and about in the same way.
And we decided --
It's not really --
Like,
I feel like a secret baby
has to be, like, two people
that aren't together.
-Yeah.
-It's a little bit
less exciting when you're like,
"We had a secret baby,"
and people are like,
"It's your third baby."
[ Laughter ]
-No, look, trust --
That's how I feel.
I mean, I don't know why
I've been keeping it a secret.
-Right.
Well, I appreciate you
biting the bullet.
[ Laughter ]
And then, you know --
you know, obviously,
the fact that this one
wasn't born in the lobby,
you know...
didn't need to run out
and tell everybody, you know?
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Fair enough.
Fair enough.
-No Netflix special there.
-Nope.
[ Laughter ]
-Boy.
-I mean, it's heartbreaking.
And, you know,
you don't want to blame her
'cause she's just a baby.
-Yeah.
-But...
You know, Axel's already
paid for college, like...
[ Laughter ]
She's got some work to do.
You know?
-Yeah.
-Hey, we're gonna
go to commercial,
but I'm gonna show you --
We're gonna go to commercial
with a video that is one
that I have watched a hundred
times since we filmed it.
This is Axel.
Both my boys
are incredibly sweet.
This is Axel.
We lower-thirded it
because he's a little hard
to understand sometimes,
but this is
his first conversation
with his baby sister.